todos si le deportará a más de un
centenar de migrantes varados en la
frontera con bolivia la mayoría de ellos
son venezolanos y las expulsiones
obedecen a razones administrativas tras
un ingreso irregular a chile todo eso
por supuesto es parte del plan colchón
en el acápite de frontera más segura
vale decir de control fronterizo es la
ley de migraciones que se modificó con
la ley muy antigua y lo mismo el decreto
265 que permite que las fuerzas armadas
en esta nueva modificación participen de
mejor forma en lo que es el apoyo de
carabineros y la pdi que son las
e instituciones establecidas por ley
para el tema fronterizo la entrada de
más de un millar de extranjeros en menos
de siete días generó tensión en la
pequeña localidad de col chana y
conocida por sus temperaturas extremas a
principios de mes dos inmigrantes
murieron congelados la oposición dice
que la mano dura de la policía en las
fronteras sólo perjudica a los
inmigrantes y que hará poco para detener
el paso de personas y estoy de acuerdo
bien aquí entra este país de manera
ilegal pero también espera recibir una
ayuda del gobierno porque con la
condición que entramos no tenemos
recursos para seguir según las
autoridades 3 mil 600 extranjeros
cruzaron ilegalmente la frontera norte
en enero 10 veces más que el año pasado